there is a super interesting article in
the new york times about
tucker carlson and journalists and
anonymous sources that i want to look at
with you today
and what's most interesting there's a
few things that are interesting about
this article one are the things we learn
about tucker carlson specifically
but also what we learn about this
relationship in terms of
trading uh for access that exists
in general in politics but also in the
political media space so let's jump
right into it the article
in the new york times called tucker
carlson calls journalists
animals he's also their best source
and the article by ben smith starts
last month i texted tucker carlson to
ask him a question that was on my mind
did you get vaccinated when was the last
time you had sex with your wife
and in what position he replied we can
trade
intimate details then we argued back and
forth about vaccines
and he ended the conversation with a
friendly invitation to return to his
show
always a good time one question you may
be asking if you're a new york times
reader is
why are you exchanging texts with tucker
carlson the fox news host who recently
described the media at large
as cringing animals who are not worthy
of respect and if you're a tucker
carlson viewer you may also be asking
how can the guy who tells you every
night that the media is lying
be texting with the enemy the answer
is one of washington's open secrets mr
carlson a proud traitor
to the elite political class spends his
time when he's not denouncing the
liberal media
trading gossip with them he's the go-to
guy for sometimes unflattering stories
about donald j
trump and for coverage of the internal
politics of fox news
not to mention stories about carlson
himself i won't talk here about any
off-the-record conversations i may have
had with him
but 16 other journalists none from the
times
told me on background that he has been
as three of them put it a great
source in trump's washington tucker
carlson
is a primary super secret source the
media writer and trump chronicler
michael wolff writes in his forthcoming
collection of essays
he explained i know this because i know
what he has told me
and i can track his exquisite too good
not to be true gossip
through unsourced reports and as it
often emerges into the accepted wisdom
so takeaway number one
is we knew it but this is confirmation
tucker carlson plays a character on his
program
um in the midst of all the anti-vaccine
stuff he's almost certainly been
vaccinated as as has his family i'm sure
um in the midst of all of his attacks on
the media
and his sort of cow towing to this
populist stuff that he does
uh he is a sort of regular
uh elite insider that communicates with
all these very same people
shouldn't surprise us we already
suspected that article goes on to say mr
carlson was particularly well positioned
to be a source about the trump
administration
his fox platform where in may he had a
nightly average of three million viewers
made him someone who mattered to trump a
close follower of television ratings he
has a former reporter's eye for detail
and anecdote
and his observations can be detected in
the lurid tales of trump's chaotic court
and fox's own tumultuous internal
politics
a coming book by the reporter michael
bender
includes a moment in which carlson sends
trump's calls to voicemail
after the first presidential debate last
fall when he was
criticized for repeatedly interrupting
joe biden when trump
finally reaches carlson the book
describes verbatim an exchange between
the two men that cast mr carlson in a
flattering light
everyone says i did a good job trump
tells carlson i don't know who told you
that was good mr carlson says
it was not good mr bender declined to
comment on the sourcing
that allowed him to so precisely
reconstruct a conversation between the
two men of course
the belief would be well the source is
tucker himself
the article continues brian stelter the
host of the cnn show reliable sources
told me quote you can see tucker's
fingerprints all over the hardcover
edition of his 2022 book
hoax which excoriates fox for amplifying
trump's falsehoods
he said he couldn't stomach talking to
carlson who has grown ever more
hard-line
for the updated paperback version that
was just released
carlson was born to a world of insiders
and story shapers and makes no secret of
it
his father was a reporter in la and san
diego before reagan appointed him
director of voice of
america and the son grew up with a
generation of elite washington
journalists
in 2018 tucker said i've always lived
around people who were wielding
authority
around the ruling class
a former new york observer media writer
sridhar papu
recalled to me that when he first
traveled to washington to cover the
white house correspondents association
dinner in the 2000s it was carlson who
asked him
do you have an invitation to tammy's
referring to the annual brunch
for media insiders co-hosted by tammy
haddad
the well-connected former msnbc producer
so here you start to get the sense
that not only is tucker not the guy
waging war on the so-called elite media
he's actually a guy trading on his
membership
in that very group in his private life
surprising
not at all not at all couple other
interesting things here
carlson said he turned against his
fellow elites after the 2008 financial
crisis
his political shift also transformed his
long journeyman's career as a writer
magazine writer and msnbc conservative
and make him fox's leading tribune
of the pro-trump masses but his decades
of washington relationships have
produced a tiresome conversation among
carlson's old friends
about what he really stands for whether
he's really a racist or whether he
cynically plays one on tv who knows and
what does it matter anyway
that's the same analysis of trump when
we've said
oh it sort of seems like trump plays coy
with anti-semitic stuff but his daughter
converted to judaism his grandkids are
jewish his son-in-law etc etc
what you have to remember is that it
doesn't actually matter in the end
if trump uh placates and coalesces that
very group
it doesn't really matter what's in his
head and that is amplified
with tucker carlson as well and the
article points out as we have
carlson's recent fixations include
suggesting the january 6th capital
insurrection was
a provocation staged by the fbi and that
making children wear masks is abuse
do we know whether that is really
tucker's view or not no we don't i
suspect it's
not uh but that is uh
something that will remain a question so
the takeaways are
tucker's just like all of these other
people there's really no difference he
is the very same type of elite that he
decries
and unfortunately and i don't want to
make this a bigger thing about populism
and grifting in general
but there is a lot of populist rhetoric
that is rhetoric alone and it is not
actually the beliefs of the individuals
behind it and that can apply on the left
and the right
on the right a lot of the populist
rhetoric is a cover for just a sort of
like
elite typical uh dude like tucker
on the left sometimes the populist
rhetoric is cover
for an authoritarian tendency which
we've also talked about before
last thing you know you might remember
donald trump's
discussions of anonymous sources
anonymous sources shouldn't be allowed
trump even seemingly misunderstanding
that an anonymous source
isn't anonymous to the journalist it's
typically that the journalist is just
saying
i won't identify you it's very
interesting that such
a notable figure on the right is
such a prominent anonymous source when
he's supposedly part of a movement that
decries the status quo of the media
which as fomented by donald trump during
his presidency
includes the criticism of the use of
anonymous sources so
nothing massively surprising in the
article it confirms a lot of things we
suspected
uh but very interesting in that our
suspicions seem to be
have been very much accurate about
tucker carlson
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video